the intimate and committed relationships
of same-sex couples just like those of
heterosexual couples provide mutual
support under the foundation of family
life in our society the argument on the
other side is that they're seeking to
redefine the institution every
definition that I looked up prior to
about a dozen years ago defined marriage
as unity between a man and a woman as
husband and wife the opportunity to
marry is integral to human dignity
excluding gay and lesbian couples from
marriage the means the dignity of these
couples it demeans their children and it
denies that both the couples and their
children the stabilizing structure that
marriage affords